foreign
is with us Robin is in Lexington
Kentucky hi Robin welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey uh thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I'm in a straight situation my
husband and I we just recently started
the baby steps which I want to say thank
you for because your program finally
convinced him that it was stupid to be
safe to be saving for retirement while
we still have debt
um and let me buy one
um so very excited to be paying that all
that off good
but um we I am a research and analyst
for
um an agency in the intelligence
Community which makes me a government
contractor so this vaccine requirements
kind of coming down the pipe for me
and I'm not one of the people that's
willing to get it
and I was wondering what your suggestion
would be about pausing paying on our
student loans and trying to like kind of
save up some money for my impending
unemployment if this were to continue
forward
well how far are we talking to the
Future you think this is a month two
months six weeks what are you hearing
um so the emails that we've gotten are
early December and of course that that's
all subjective right so I mean I haven't
seen the actual executive order come out
yet I haven't you know there's a the
lawsuits aren't done yet I mean there's
there's
a million things that could happen but
I'm I'm a planner and
if I get fired from this job because for
this reason I don't have skills to get
paid the same level outside of
government work how do you know I'm not
saying you're wrong but I want you to
answer that how do you know that as a
research analyst and the kind of work
you do that that's not transferable
outside well I'm specific typically a
language enabled research analyst
Chinese language for future threats
Technologies so it's not there's not a
huge Market out there for that and now I
could apply my language and that ability
to other things but they wouldn't pay on
the same I totally understand but let me
also share with you that yes that's a
super super specific position but the
fact of the matter is Chinese language
and that that linguistic skill aside
you're really good at research you're
really good at analyzing things true or
false
true well I I'm just going to challenge
you that uh what do you make now
um I'm making 80 000 and this is my
basically
I'm I'm in line for you know do this for
a year and they bump you up about 20
grand so yeah have you done any research
out in the marketplace to see what's out
there near 80 grand doing that type of
work forget the specific nature I mean I
don't know about research I did look for
a job for eight months when we got
kicked out of China to come back here
because of covet in the first place
um and I was unsuccessful I finally
found a job in local government doing
well I I really enjoyed it
um but it paid about half of what I'm
making now
um so I I don't know about research but
I know that it's really really hard to
get a job with Chinese language research
analyst and not a ton of
um
of experience in the in the field sure
well again I'm gonna I'm Really Gonna
challenge you you are a researcher by
nature and I think you've got to take
this really serious I think just to
assume well I'm gonna have to this is
all I'm gonna have to pause my baby
steps to try to weather this as opposed
to what can I do that's proactive uh I
think that's what you've got to be doing
right now and I think you have so much
experience and so much skill that's
transferable you've got to be looking
into what corporate jobs uh that are are
good fit for me and if I'm making 70 but
I think just to assume that you can't
make 80 I think that's uh you got some
more work to do on that I really would
challenge you to do some homework
okay and I
while you're doing that I have to agree
with your initial idea too I'm gonna
stop the baby steps and pile up cash
because I'm gonna until you land
something else you know I think there's
a real high heavy probability you're
going to be done there if you're
unwilling to be vaccinated and so
um I think the president has made it
pretty obvious what his intent is on
that and the only question is whether he
is has the power to pull it off or not
before we get slammed with 5 000 or 50
000 on you know constitutional
challenging uh lawsuits which is what's
going to happen but the question is that
is that going to save your job I don't I
don't know and I would be pretty
pessimistic about that in this
environment so yeah I'm gonna stop and
pile up cash but I'm also going to start
re-analyzing how your skills fit into
the marketplace at Ken's suggestion and
see if you can't land something
that's there maybe even some some
independent things that aren't
government contracts but maybe you're
just Contracting out uh to defense
contractors and so forth but even those
I think the uh
the president's going to try to anything
that touches the federal government is
going to try to hit it and uh so it's
it's going to be a it's going to be a
lot of
arguing going on before things are
decided it's not as easy as the stroke
of a pen
in a democracy so right or wrong that's
going to be your facts so um yeah I'm
going to pile up cash for a while here
until until I I feel like I've got a
greater than 50 percent chance of
staying
um and and then once you've got that
then you know you can calm down a little
bit